but he's like dating Gigi Hadid and my
whole mind is blown
Jojo Fletcher is just like the rest of
us her mind is blown by Tyler Cameron's
recent dates with Gigi Hadid it's crazy
et caught up with the former
Bachelorette and her fiance Jordan
Rogers at NBC's Television Critics
Association summer press tour on
Thursday where they were promoting their
new show cash pad we team up with
homeowners we help them renovate their
properties that are a little
unconventional and we turned them into
short-term rentals so I've been doing
this for like the last ten years when we
got together he started helping me with
my renovation dragged me into it I
didn't see that in the fine print yeah
and they couldn't help but weigh in on
Hanna Brown's runner-ups outings with
the supermodel he's single by with Hanna
what I feel great absolutely no I would
feel really crappy remember I feel like
he should just do what he wants it makes
him happy she should do what she wants
they're both single
they also dished on how Tyler's dates
with Gigi could affect his chance at
being the next Bachelor I feel like on
one hand you're like yeah maybe because
like your bachelor should be like ready
for love not going on a date with Gigi
but then again it's like oh I think that
he's obviously thing on he wants to find
and meet girls and they may be his soul
mate Gigi maybe his soul mate can you
imagine what that would be and while
things are heating up with Gigi and
Tyler Jojo and Jordan revealed their
picks for the next Bachelor
I like my
and I like Peter Peter I like my
computer
I think it's time to have a black
bachelor I think Mike's amazing I think
he is so handsome and I I would love to
see that happen but I also see Peter is
very charming and sweet and I think
people fell in love with him as far as
he went so I would be happy with either
one that might might voted that might
for a while for now the couple is
planning their own nuptials but don't
expect all of bachelor nation to get an
invite well invite people that we're
close to but no I wouldn't say it's like
a crate gonna be a crazy big wedding
probably average things are expensive
and yes they said their piece on the
Blake Kaelin paradise drama that has
bachelor nation split I think everyone's
kind of at fault I think that like I
don't I honestly don't know what's going
on I've read like Twitter and I see the
stuff I think that he felt like he was
back into a corner I feel like he didn't
feel like he accurately presented I got
his story out he and she in and who
knows what the truth is I mean none of
us really know but I feel like there's a
way to go about these situations it
sucks that has to be so public it's not
it's just stressful it's anxiety filled
[Music]
[Applause]